Now, before we write the second part of this
program, I want you to experiment with built-in functions.
Pick anyone of the built-in functions, read through their
documentation. By the way, the link to this page is
available in the instructor notes. Use your chosen built-in
functions in a new program and then share your
experiences on the forum. You should answer questions like:
Which built in function did you actually decide to use?
What did your program do? And what problems did you run into?
By the way, being able to read documentation and experimenting with Python, is
a big part of learning how to program. Once you've posted your
responses on the forum, feel free to check this box before you continue.